[Music]
Hey There Will Smith talks about I am
Legend 2 but there's also new info on
Deadpool 3 Zack Snider's new 300 sequel
Johnny Depp as Satan and plenty more now
in the Koch Che
news now it's official Will Smith
confirms the previous rumors about the
plot of I am Legend 2 the story is said
to pick up on the alternative ending of
its predecessor in the 2007 movie
theater version of the horror Thriller I
Am Legend the main character Robert is
attacked by the infected and dies
however the alternative ending which was
only included in the home Cinema version
tells the story in a different manner in
it Robert sets his captives free and the
alleged monsters disappear again he sets
off with other survivors on a journey to
one of the last camps where other humans
still exist the sequel I am Legend 2 is
to follow on for precisely this ending
as Will Smith announced at the Red Sea
International film festival in Saudi
Arabia Smith will be joined by Creed
actor Michael B Jordan in an undisclosed
role early rumors suggest he could play
Robert's son the eagerly awaited sequel
Still Remains without a director so it
will probably take some time before we
can finally watch the movie on the big
screen ugly or cute that's the question
Deadpool 3 is back with a new image in
addition to Ryan Reynolds as Wade Wilson
we also get to see his new sidekick
dogol
his verdict on Instagram looks like
avocado tastes like dog dogpool has
previously made appearances in several
Deadpool comics and is a member of the
Deadpool Corp his distinctive appearance
is the result of experiments with
Cosmetics which eventually mutated him
and gave him the power of self-healing
after Deadpool 3 had a more than messy
first production phase shooting is now
back in progress we can therefore expect
some New Impressions from the film set
in the near future in addition to
dogpool other Heroes will also be
featured in Deadpool 3 alongside Hugh
Jackman as Wolverine Electra played by
Jennifer Garner will also make an
appearance there are also rumors of a
reunion with Ben Affleck's Daredevil
Ghost Rider and Gambit fun chaos appears
to be inevitable we look forward to the
hopefully final theatrical release of
Deadpool 3 on July 26th
2024 will we be able to watch the final
part of the 300 Saga after all if
director Zack Snider has his way at
least as he has now regained the rights
to blood and Ashes with the extremely
bloody 300 Snyder created a movie that
is still very popular to this day almost
8 years later a sequel was made with 300
Rise of an Empire for which Snider only
worked as a producer in the years that
followed the director devoted himself
mostly to the superhero genre
nevertheless he continued to write a 300
sequel at the same time which was to be
called blood and Ashes blood and Ashes
is about the the love relationship
between Alexander the Great and his
General haasan according to Snider the
movie was intended to be something
between a love story and a visually
stunning War epic however after the
breakup with Warner the project was put
on hold for a while as Snyder lost the
rights to his own work however it now
seems that we might get to see the movie
after all as Snider revealed in an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter he
was able to regain the rights and is now
looking to realize the project elsewhere
he said he didn't know what the
marketplace for an incredibly homoerotic
super violent super sexual movie would
look like but maybe it would be perfect
we can easily imagine that the film
could be made in collaboration with
Netflix after all the streaming service
and SNY have already teamed up
successfully for Army of the dead and
the science fiction two-part film Rebel
Moon so the chances for another 300
movie aren't that bad at
all news from the world of the friendly
spider Amazon is currently developing a
Spider-Man series for which a special
co- showrunner has been secured as
variety reports Steve Lightfoot who was
also responsible for the Punisher series
will be involved in Spider-Man Dew it
was announced back in February of this
year that Amazon was working on a series
adaptation of the popular character
Spider-Man Noir is an alternative
version of Spider-Man and has already
been seen in Sony Spider-Man Into the
spiderverse Now the character is to be
given his own series set in 1930s New
York during the Great Depression besides
silk spider Society spider man Noir is
one of two projects to be made by Amazon
it is currently not known whether other
characters from the Spider-Man universe
will also make an appearance after all
Sony holds the rights to the majority of
the
characters Barbie has made over $1.4
billion and many are wondering will
there be a sequel according to Margo
Robbie and Greta Gerwig it might turn
out a little differently than expected
Margo Robbie keeps saying the same thing
about Barbie too the first part is a
movie that stands on its own everything
had already been put into it and she
could not imagine a sequel in the
program 60 Minutes Overtime director
Greta Gerwig and her co-writer Noah
bombach talked about the project they
also discussed the things that didn't
make it into the finished film the two
had plenty of other ideas for the
character of Ryan Gosling's Ken
especially for the Ken effect in the
real world there was even a scene in
which Ken meets the real Ryan Gosling
the actor was the preferred choice for
the role from the very beginning and was
already mentioned by his full name in
the first draft of the script according
to gerwick they had far too much
material on the character at this point
in the interview bomack interrupts his
partner telling her not to give too much
away when asked whether a separate Ken
movie was planned the director laughs
saying she couldn't comment on that if a
Barby spin-off with Ryan Gosling were to
happen however it would probably take
some time Gerwig has recently signed a
contract with Netflix to direct two new
The Chronicles of Narnia
movies Johnny Depp could soon be taking
on a very special role the popular actor
is set to play none other than the Devil
Himself according to variety cult
director and former M python member
Terry Gilliam wants to cast depth in his
next movie carnival at the end of days
at the Red Sea Festival he described the
plot as follows God is wiping out
Humanity because they have ruined Earth
the only one who wants to save it is the
devil after all without humans he would
have no job for all of eternity so
Johnny Depp AKA Satan looks for a few
young people and tries to convince God
that they are the new Adam and Eve the
83-year-old Gilliam is convinced that he
could persuade Johnny Depp to star in
the comedy the two have already worked
together on The Imaginarium of Dr prases
in his initially unsuccessful Don keyote
film The disastrous filming was
perpetuated in the film Lost in Lanka
years later he was still able to bring
the man who killed Don keyote to
theaters but with Adam Driver and
Jonathan price in the leading roles the
director is definitely persistent and
there's a good chance that we will soon
be able to see Johnny Depp as the devil
carnival at the end of days is still in
the early stages of development meaning
a release date is not yet
foreseeable Angelina Julie is returning
as the dark fairy Maleficent the actress
has now revealed that part three of the
Disney film series is currently in the
works the fantasy film Maleficent was
released in 2014 and was a huge success
for the studio in it Jolie plays the
apotamus evil fairy who made her grand
entrance as the villain in Disney's
animated classic Sleeping Beauty back in
1959 the liveaction movie was followed
by Maleficent 2 Mistress of evil in 2019
since then many have been wondering
whether the series will be continued in
an interview with the Wall Street
Journal Angelina Julie stated that she
currently has five projects scheduled
with Maleficent 3 being one of them
according to rumors J Colette Sarah is
on the short list to direct the project
a date for the theatrical release of
Maleficent three is not yet known after
all Jolie has four other movie projects
to complete she has a speaking role in
Kung Fu Panda 4 for example which is due
to be released on March 29th 2024 in
addition she is currently filming the
Maria Callis biopic Maria working on the
Espionage Thriller mod versus mod with
Hal Berry and the drama every note
played with Kristoff
Waltz thanks to the Comic-Con in Brazil
we've got tons of new trailers for you
for example make sure you check out the
trailers for The Fallout Amazon series
as well as the one for Godzilla X Kong
the new Empire for some awesome action
you can find all the release trailers
here on our Channel and of course we
also want to know what you have to say
about this week's news so drop a line in
the comments and let us know your
thoughts we look forward to your
[Music]
opinion